safety committee as chair of the
criminal justice and public safety
committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of october 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing with the
potential for an executive session to be
held throughout
please note that there is a fiscal
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
the public has access to contemporaries
and listen
when it's necessary to participate in
this zoom meeting
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available from the house calendar
through the electronic calendar on the
general pro website
notice this meeting implies
if the house holds in rsa 91 dash
anyone who has a problem assessing
accessing the meeting should call 271
3600 email hcs
lag.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting
us brad rieben who's the committee
researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this
meeting shall be done by a roll call
vote
let's start the meeting by thinking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting just requiring a
right to know
and just for clarifications and this was
discussed during the last meeting
we are taking a roll call vote your
cameras must
remember statistically please have your
cameras on
but if you're if your camera's not on uh
anytime the question is put you'd have
to consider
being present in your seat
here representative greene here
representative wallace representative
testerman here
representative true yeah in the
committee room representative pratt
yeah representative marston
alone in my office representative newman
here and home alone representative
here at home by myself representative
conley
representative knight here with family
in another room
representative bradley here with my
daughters
representative wallace president in the
room
perry gathering
[Music]
mr chairman yeah
jeremy oh cheers
mr chairman i do know that
representative gathering is here
representative colin will be joining us
at this time i'll recognize
representative martin pledge of
allegiance
amen
yes
oh
[Music]
at this time we are going to reopen the
executive session on
house bill 408.
[Music]
thank you mr chairman i would like to
make a motion uh for reconsideration for
how
much work is there a second to that
motion again
that second invite verizon
said rosie mr speaking yes thank you mr
chairman
um while i was preparing the majority of
work for
health before a week there were some
concerns that i found that i
did not i guess just looking at the
particles the things i didn't see
that that i saw when i was reading the
work and
some of these things that i think we can
fix to make this still still impassable
but how it is right now
yes i'm just curious why
the reconsideration is the inbound
i believe that there's some potential
for some amendments to the bill
what i've heard at least would have been
expressed to me
one of the concerns was that the
language involving
reasonable
specific type of jobs but
i think it would the term repeat
interaction with the minor
there was some some
some concerns over how that would apply
we did hear some testimony on that and
there was some discussion during
the public hearings that apply to the
clerk of the convenience stores
i think it would make sense for us to
maybe look into putting
some clarification of what that term
would be
thank the other you was
for an employer and it says that they
can be notified poorly or in writing
it is probably best practice to make
that done in writing
i would recommend all going to do it in
writing but
[Music]
i just needed to know um what bill you
were just talking about that's
all host bill 408
okay thank you for reconsideration that
was made
you guys already voted oh yes
okay representative death rate yes
roll call attendance did you verify for
me you were here
yes i am present i'm presently in this
room alone
thank you you're welcome representative
you're recognized thank you mr chairman
uh
i'm gonna vote against the motion
you know i think you know
you know i'm not seeing any major issues
um that a small amendment on the house
floor
would take care of so i just thought
that this bill should go forward because
in my eyes um which i think
with a 15 to 16 vote i think the
committee
agrees with that so that's why
yes mr chairman uh could you refresh my
memory on why the uh
sergeant of state police objected to
this bill
i'm unable to specify the depression
on their specific objection of why they
opposed it
i might just i don't remember who said
this but
the rest of the opposition wasn't really
the policy
that this bill i think the policy was
really accepted by um most
most individuals i just think that the
application of that
term
uh and it says repeat the interaction is
combined
and i think i think we all agree that
if you're a teacher for example in a
school
that would apply to that so would it
apply to someone working in a grocery
store
at checkout and it i'm not saying that
it does or doesn't
i think it would make sense to clarify
what is a repeated interaction
with the with the child it does have
you know the prior internet sentences
which
purposes involves the direct care
instruction or guidance or repeating
directional charges
i think it's important from a legal
perspective because the employers may
violate that provision of realizing
their violence
i think they would be liable i think
for them for employers i think it's
important
seeing no further representative hopper
are you recognized
uh thank you mr chair i'm gonna vote for
reconsideration because i
i was uh during the hearing i was
bothered by the idea that
that repeated interact with children
is pretty vague so
if i was an employer because when we
talk
when we send somebody to prison for
something and they get out
they should have a reasonable
possibility of rehabilitating themselves
that possibility is limited if they
can't find a job
if i was a an employer and i looked at
this law
i would be very hesitant to hire
somebody who's working even in a
convenience store
because under this it would be repeated
interaction with a minor although it was
not
an uh close interaction that could that
would likely lead to any kind of abuse
still be a liability issue if something
did happen
so i i think we do have to uh
narrow that that deal down to make this
uh better so i i'm gonna vote for
reconsideration
thank goodness you expand on that an
employer can hire someone
and then they can be in compliance but
if a customer
or a minor comes into the store a
certain amount of times all of a sudden
the employer is no longer complying and
i think
having some specifics when that would
apply
at least to look into how we can maybe
tailor definitions
that would be interesting
see no further hands raised
and for the members who are
participating remotely once the ques
once the question is put the camera
would need
i'm trying hold on there i am
i'm sorry oh yeah
seeing no further humans race the matter
will now be put to question
the motion for reconsideration please
say yay if you are opposed
do you say nay
yes
representative greene
yes representative wallace
yes representative testerman yes
representative representative craft
representative marston
no park votes yes
representative harry gaffrey
yes
yes representative ordnae
yes representative muse
yes representative newman
yes representative
yes representative conley
representative point knight yes
representative bradley yes
chairman the chair votes yes your
chairman of the vote is 18
i voted 18 years and two nays the motion
for reconsideration has passed
at this time the chair recognized
representatives
thank you mr chairman i'd like to make
motion to obtain household 408.
that has been seconded by representative
gaffery
mr chairman thank you i believe we've
had all the discussions when we
discussed containing it
observing
it was previously off voted off the pass
i believe by about 15 to six
yes
thank you
seeing no hands raised
true thank you mr chair um i voted
against the bill
uh originally uh because i
found uh so many problems with the way
it was written
one of them was the verbally or inviting
that the employer would have to make
sure it was followed
even though the law says the employee
has to do it
that there's i had problems with
the the person who has already
been sentenced and served his punishment
was still being punished uh years later
because of his previous crime
so now i guess the motion what we're
faced with here is to go ahead and
rewrite the entire bill
um we can do that we can do that with
every bill
that comes before the committee
we change everything and rewrite every
bill we don't have the time to do that
we have a law on the books
concerning this i don't
i don't see what the purpose of
retaining will be other than to
sit down invite an entirely new girl
so i can't support uh i can't support
behavior
representative knight thank you cara i
um agree with uh representative true
that i i don't find this necessary and
i find that if it were to pass
as as it is right now that
um unforeseen people would be losing
their jobs that are in rehabilitation
that was discussed because we weren't
clearly defining things
uh repeat
of repeat people working at a
convenience store
or what does that even mean so there's a
lot of language that was unclear
that was open-ended that could turn into
um a lot of gray areas
so i think this needs a lot of work and
i think it needs to be a whole new bill
thank you
i mean chairman abbas um i just got a
message from the house clerk
he just wants to um inform you about a
procedural
matter if you would like to have him
speak
yes
uh good morning mr chairman members of
the committee uh i just wanted to inform
you uh just very briefly of the the
situation
so uh you you voted for reconsideration
the issue now is that the motion before
you
is back to what the motion that was
adopted previously is
so you can't substitute a new motion
until you dispose of the original motion
so the motion before you is the original
ought to pass as you passed it
okay so i just wanted to to point that
out in order to
entertain a retained motion you have to
defeat this motion
because these could the author pass be
withdrawn
uh it's been it's
i guess technically it could
if if both the mover and the original
seconder
withdraw their motions
anyway i just wanted to to to bring that
to your attention thanks very much folks
sorry to bother you thank you
you need the motion about the task
the second directive so my understanding
is
that the emotion about the task was made
initially by representative rhodes and
then that was seconded
by representative welsh i guess
representative rhodes he wished
withdrawals
[Music]
either way the so the two the two
members who made the most about the past
and seconded
both in toronto i think for the sake of
vote where
for procedure lists make the motion
series again the
it could be done if it was the it was
defeated then
consideration you might understand the
clerk
suggested that if it could be withdrawn
provided both
the members who made the initial motion
about the
representative rhodes to make a motion
to everything
thank you mr chairman i'd like to make a
motion to continue for a week
second again by representative
representative you were recognized uh
thank you mr chairman
um before
the to remove the op to pass i was just
the question i had was where's the
committee filed so we could confirm
that's what was happening what happened
who made the motions
because it sounded like there was some
you know while we think it was me
but i just want to
see the file and make sure that that's
what happened
because i don't remember who made the
motions
oh you did okay that is the way it is
mr chairman you know yeah you rolled it
down tonight
i'm certain that i made the notion of
what's passed because i have down
syndrome
okay sounded like there was some
confusion that's all i want to make sure
that is correct
you say that it is thank you
i'm a little bit confused but when we
first had this motion about to pass
did we not take it yes
we did on february 20th what was the
result of that roll call
uh the result of the that
the vote for the phone call was not the
past 15
days and six minutes
and and then what we we we changed
and we we did it there was this morning
we did a motion for reconsideration
and that that that passes between two by
eighty two one
in any event the motion reconsideration
has passed
uh the clerk
once you reconsider the motion about the
gas is still on the table or not
open we need to dispose of this right
which we could have disposed of it by
defeating
it or the members who offered it to the
cross
the members who offered it was offered
by representative rhodes
and the second better welsh they both
withdrew
the initial a second
so now representative rose has been
recognized during the motion transition
that was seconded by representative
gathering
thank you
i just have a question i again i
understand the clerk
jumped in and speaking tomorrow
hello it's better hello
okay well i'll try this um
can you hear me yes
can you hear me in the room
okay well i just wanted to say that i
the clerk jumped in but uh i just have a
problem with the
vote being done before and now we're
withdrawing it with no vote i don't know
how that's going to look
on paper
so motions have been withdrawn on
several occasions
in this this year an example was
[Music]
i'll use representative preston's bill
as an example the one involving
the summonses on good behavior he
initially made a motion to applaud the
past
he went through that we'd have accepted
by representative martin they both
withdrew their out to pass
and then follow that up with a motion to
phoenix so we've withdrawn motion
several times
that uh without taking a roll call vote
to withdraw so it's been done i
understand the paper would be confusing
we do have the benefit of obviously
having a live reporting as well
so i don't i don't believe there'll be
any confusion to the public
the bill has never never left our
committee so
there's no there's nothing on the docket
showing that it was
it has passed
i would just say that we've never we've
always been drawing it before a vote
but this was already voted and now
we reconsider it that's what i'm trying
to state
i i think it's a it's a valid concern
and it wouldn't hurt
the emotions already being withdrawn and
then
we've already recognized another motion
so
i i guess if we were going to vote to do
the to withdraw the ought to pass
we may have we may have gone past that
the only way to do that would be to
withdraw the
motion to retain but i think we're just
going around
that's creating more confusion but i do
appreciate the concern raised
representative rose thank you mr
chairman just to clarify i
i did text the clerk because there was
some confusion in the room
and he is still on our call and he has
informed me that yes we did the
reconsideration was correct
then myself making the motion to
withdraw the about to pass
representative while seconding that was
exactly what we needed to do and now we
are
thumbs up to go forward with the
retaining
thank you mr chairman if i recall right
representative this
right i should have voted on it the
example you gave us
i don't think there was an actual vote i
think there was a motion
then we discussed then they said oh okay
well maybe we should make a different
motion
then they would drown their they would
draw their motion i don't think there
was ever a boat
like this this was an actual boat that
we you know we might be able to do it
according to the clerk it just doesn't
look good you know the public's looking
going who
what the hell's going on and in my eyes
you know we should have hold it
a piece of paper i understand what
you're saying and representing
also noticed that distinguished by
example
by pointing out that there was an actual
quote done on hd
i will say i'll say the same thing i'll
repeat it but i think the representation
i'll say again
that practice may have been a good
receiver to follow the problems we've
read now
that most of them were drawn and there's
now a motion to routine
that would have to be what's wrong in
order to do that okay if the motion's
already been withdrawn
how do we load on something that's
moving stronger i think that the
my point is the time to deal with what's
being recommended
may be best practice but it's also
passed
we should
there is still a record of our what
we're doing and again we're
live streaming this is recorded
for the entire world watching i i don't
believe there'll be any
disservices see
seeing no hands raised
representative newman representative i
recommend uh turning on your
video device from seven new one you
recognize
yes mr speaker and i just have a
parliamentary inquiry i thought i heard
someone say
move the motion and i'm wondering if
that's correct
you're asking if someone someone made a
recommendation to move the question
uh i would say that if
that's i'm not just mr chair just to
clarify i'm not questioning whether that
was correct or not i just wanted to know
if i heard it
and may have and may have a follow-up
when a motion
to move the question is made i believe
that it needs to have a vote and it has
to be passed by two thirds
thank you mr chairman uh i believe
actually
in the masons manual that in committee
that
no one no member can make a motion to
lose the question
that's that's not permitted in the
committee that's in the that
in any conversations you hear between
myself representative wallace uh it's
it's us
it's a recommendation on emotion but
anyway at this time
seeing no hands raised the matter will
now be put to question if you were in
favor of the motion to retain
let's go forward please say yay and
opposed please working up all the rules
chairman welch aye representative burke
no representative hopper
yes representative greene no
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true
mary
representative pratt
representative marston no
clark votes yes representative harriet
gathering
yes representative cantalakis
yes representative o'hart
yes representative gordon a
yes representative muse
yes representative newman
yes representative
yes representative conley
yes representative klein knight
no representative bradley
no chairman what's your host yes
mr sharon the vote is 15
to six by a vote of
15 years
[Music]
not six
this time we'll close the executive
session on
hospital 408
and it will remain in recess until
10 am
watching the hamstrings
i meet yourself mrs damon
um i did not receive that bill in the
mail
i don't know about anybody else but i'm
not able
to print out those um
bills and i think it's very unfair that
we have to work at home
and don't know what's going on and i
hope we can cure that
representative what i will do is
try to make sure that for any whether
it's a second committee assignment
or senate bill that gets assigned to us
will be mailed will be mailed to
committee members
thank you a member doesn't have a
schedule and the member does not have
the bill uh try to reach out to
the committee assistant or to depart
by jennifer rhodes and ask ask
cn
know that we're working from home and
shouldn't they be doing
that i think every member should have
should have access to the bill that
where
it's a public hearing executive session
thank you that's
no i i'm just getting used to you
zoom i take one step at a time
i really don't know how to do it
i know it's them i'm with you on this
one
thank you very much
[Music]
so
systems
[Music]
so
me
[Music]
this time open the public hearing
on senate bill 34 it's relative to the
definition of a controlled drug
giving the sale possession of synthetic
urine and urine
is there a sponsor present to introduce
senator quickly
this time please raise your hand
mr german i don't see any senators on my
list here
[Music]
i mean mr chair i know um senator
d'alessandro was planning on testifying
on this bill today he is having some
technical difficulties he is um calling
it now
i believe he might have just called in
you want me to allow that number mr
chairman yes
here he is hi uh is this
is this representative albus yeah yes
representatives this is senator de la
sandra sorry for all the confusion but
our our internet is down here and we've
got a
bid working on an upgrade of fixing our
system our phones are down
so i'm speaking to you um
with that with the cell phone so i
appreciate your patience and your
courtesy
it's no problem senator you uh the chair
when i recognize you to
introduce senator bill well thank you
very much
for the record i'm senator lou d'alessio
i represent district 20.
manchester awards 3 4 10 11 the town of
goffstown
and i come before you uh as the brave
sponsor of senate bill 34 f1
senate bill 34 fn was senate bill 709 fn
in the 2020 section
it passed the senate was passed on to
the house but it was tabled in the house
due to the suspension of legislative
activity as a result of the coaliti
pandemic here's what senate bill
34 fn does senate bill 34 fn
is brought forward at the request of the
new hampshire department of safety
and the former b chester police chief
david mara who works in the governor's
office
senate bill 34 fn does three things
it it inserts a new definition of
controlled drug
in log it inserts a prohibition or the
sale of possession of synthetic urine
and urine additives and it repeals
obsolete statutes governing the sale of
synthetic drugs
there are people from the new hampshire
department of safety here to speak of
the specifics of senate bill
bill 34 fn but the purpose of xenophil
34 fn is to give law enforcement the
tools they
need to combat synthetic drugs
i thank all of you for allowing me to
speak be
before you at this point in time but i
appreciate the uh
the problems that result as as a result
of a telecommunications situation but
uh thank you so much and if you have any
questions i'd be more than happy to
address them but
people from dos uh department of safety
will be here and
i'm sure that they have um all of the
answers that you need so mr chairman
thank you so much
you have a great great great american
day and uh thank you and every
person of the community for their
service
thank you senator
senior answers uh excused
if there are any members of the public
who are in attendance that
wish to please raise your hand
at this time the chair will recognize
what's the statement
good morning thank you very much my name
is melissa staples i'm the director of
the new hampshire state police forensic
laboratory
and i am here to provide some
information about
what this bill accomplishes why was it
needed
and of course this bill is certainly
supported by the department
so i'd like to address the second part
of the legislation which pertains
specifically to the drug
analogs which starts on page 1 line 19.
around 2012 synthetic drugs such as
spice
k2 and bath salts became readily
available
requiring law enforcement and medical
personnel to respond to numerous
overdoses on a daily basis
many in public locations in fact by 2014
these drugs led then governor maggie
hassan to declare state of emergency
due to the extreme public health threat
legislation put in place at the time was
successful in quelling the distribution
of these drugs
however drug analogs such as additional
bath salts are becoming prevalent once
again
particularly in the western part of the
state this is causing medical
emergencies and increases in crime
but the current law does not support
prosecution for these drugs
the current law regarding what is
considered to be a drug analog
is essentially unenforceable and i'd
like to take a moment to explain why
the first part of the current verbiage
for
the definition of a controlled drug
analog reads as follows
control dog drug analog means a
substance that has a chemical structure
substantially similar to that of a
controlled drug
and that was specifically designed to
produce an effect
substantially similar to that of a
controlled drug
and there are problems with each of
those two components of the definition
first substantially similar structure is
not defined
the word substantially is a relative
term which does not establish a clear
legal standard
which leaves prosecutors without a clear
standard on which to base their charges
or to prove a case second
specifically designed to produce an
effect substantially similar to that of
a controlled drug
would require prosecutors to know what
the person who manufactured the drug was
thinking
what their intent was when they produced
the drug
clearly this is almost impossible to
prove
the proposed language in this bill
solves both of these problems
first there is a new definition of
substantially similar structure which is
provided on page 2 line 10
which goes into detail about what this
term means so it's no longer
a relative term that could be up for
interpretation
secondly the intent of the manufacturer
is replaced
with the ability to produce laboratory
studies which show
this analog to essentially have the same
effect as the original drug
and that portion is on page 1 line 23.
these studies would show things like the
drug binds with the same receptors in
the body as the controlled drug
communication with the dea indicates
that they're pretty quick to produce
those studies
which then support the effect
scientifically rather than trying to
determine the person's intended effect
when they manufactured the drug
chapter 359-0 which had is being
repealed on page
2 line 18 was a stopgap measure put in
place to prohibit the sale of spice in
retail establishments
this was put in place at a time when
people could purchase spice at your
corner market
and it made it a violation to sell those
types of analogs and was successful in
getting the product off the shelves
but then when they went to the black
market the analog wall really couldn't
be enforced
but with a new definition of analog the
section of 359.0 is no longer needed as
sales and retail establishments could be
prosecuted under the new definition
as a felony the news section 359-0
regarding synthetic urine
um synthetic urines for those who who
may not be familiar with that
really have no legitimate purpose
they're designed specifically to provide
blank urine samples for those who must
take drug tests
perhaps as a condition of employment
like a cdl license
or if someone is on probation or parole
or maybe even as part of a rehab program
these products are cylinder names such
as quick fix
ultra pure magnum detox
and an individual utilizing these
synthetic urines could be putting others
at risk
for example in the case of a a cdl
driver who may be using drugs and
driving on our highways
it could prevent people from receiving
services such as someone who might be in
rehab
who may be still using but providing
clean urine samples
which could be beneficial to those
individuals
so i just wanted to take a moment to
clarify the purpose of this legislation
it is very important
and i'm happy to answer any questions
you may have for me
representative boyd you're recognized
thank you mr chair oh thank you for
taking my question
i use stated that there was no there is
no use for
uh synthetic urine but my understanding
is synthetic urine is used to calibrate
uh medical instruments and also my
understanding is that
uh non-human uh synthetic urine is used
to attract uh animal as well as
to repel animals are these are these not
legitimate
uses i thank you for your question uh
quite honestly being in the forensic
realm i'm not familiar with those other
uses
um i think the intent of this
legislation is really to
ban the common sale of these things uh
so that they are very much
um being able to be uh
received by the individuals who are
using it for the purposes i described
um however as you mentioned there could
be other potential uses that i'm not
aware of
thank you you're welcome
representative fine night you're
recognized for a question
um thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um are you aware that there was a lot
past the house in 2017
that specifically for synthetic urine
so that consumers can still purchase it
for
what representative boarding a was
suggesting and also
we can go after criminals using it to
cheat drug tests
how would this differ is this updating
the law or
can you elaborate on what how this
differs from the 2017 law
you know i wish i could i do remember
testifying on the same subject
several years ago and i kind of
honestly i kind of lost track of what
had happened with that legislation
i'd be happy to review it um if you had
the number for me but at this point
i'd like to review it before i had
comment on how this may be different
uh saying no for the hands raised i want
to make the witness
[Music]
good good morning mr chair and members
of the committee
my name is bob oxley and i am the
director of field services for the
department of corrections
and the department of corrections
supports sb 34.
i'll be very brief this morning as i've
submitted written testimony but i want
to
emphasize a few key points
sb 34 would change how new hampshire
currently defines a controlled
drug analog this bill would
appropriately change the definition
focusing on the chemistry
and makeup of the drug rather than the
drug dealer's intent
these drug analogs started in sullivan
county about five years ago
and we've now seen them in several other
counties and becoming
a problem as drug dealers continue to
get more sophisticated in the area of
controlled drug analogs we expect to see
more in the future throughout the state
sb 34 would allow our probation parole
office to to
focus on combating these sophisticated
synthetic drugs
and will improve the lives and
opportunities for those in the
communities
mostly impacted by them again i said
it'd be brief but i am available for
questions
representative recognized her question
uh thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um on the on the last part of the of the
bill
chapter 359 oh sale possession of
synthetic uh
isn't the sale in possession of
synthetic urine against
the law in new hampshire now
thank you for the question um i'm not
certain but i'll i'll certainly find out
i know it's it's a problem
for the probation of parole officers
throughout the state
you know when they when they use it when
when being tested
it's for no other reason to disguise
their illegal activity
but but i will find out i'm not sure if
the current law has that or not
you're recognized for a question thank
you mr chairman and uh
thank you uh for taking my question
how many other states currently have
you know similar or this law in use and
does it work oh thank you for the
question that's a great question
and again i apologize i'm not sure how
many other states but i'll certainly
find out and report back
all right thank you
seeing no uh representative bourne
you're recognized
thank you mr chair uh i do have answers
to the
questions that mr burt asked there are
18 states that now make synthetic urine
banned and
rsa 259 colon
o does uh prevent
synthetic urine in the state
thank you
[Music]
seeing knowing hands raised i want to
thank the witness for his testimony
witnesses excuse me thank you
[Music]
if there's any members of the public or
present or wish to testify that if not
that's not already this time please
raise your hand
seeing no hands raised
this time we will now close up on the
hearing on senate bill 34.
hmm
this time we will open the executive
session
on house bill 632
[Music]
representative rogers thank you mr
chairman i'd like to make a motion to
entertain house bill 632
is there a second okay
seconded by representative welch
thank you mr chairman there's a lot of
great intent behind this bill that i
have to agree with a lot of testimonies
considering a person's age and the
decisions that we're able to make
and with that being said it kind of led
us to more questions about
patterns repeating behavior
just need some more senator tessen
thank you
the work that we have ahead of us
in 632 i don't know how you
how you fix this without caveats with
your industry
or problems
representative klein knight you're
recognized
thank you chair um i really
find that uh retaining this is
it's really a disheartening move i think
that
this bill is perfect it simply clarifies
that we're not going to be condemning
a child in our state from the right to
be heard before a court of their peers
we're simply denying them our right to
be heard
forever for the rest of their lives when
they did something
when they didn't have fully developed
frontal lobes
i don't think it's up to us to condemn
anybody in that situation
and really again this is just to allow
someone the opportunity to have their
voice heard
they can then you know by case-by-case
basis
deny that person if they're not on the
track to rehabilitation
and there's a course correction made for
each individual
that is in the criminal justice system
by denying
this to minors you are condemning them
for the rest of their lives
i cannot support this retained motion i
think it does a disservice to
all children that could be caught in a
terrible situation
thank you
representative manager it's not about
the bill
i'm not able to hear very clearly when
people in the room are
speaking it's very uh i wanted to know
if it was just on my side or
everybody else i can hear who are on
uh zoom but when some members
in the room speak it's very choppy just
wanted to
ask if i'm the only one i can check my
side and then another member
who's working remotely did someone
second that
a system problem
representative bourdain
thank you i have to agree with
representative klein knight that this
bill is very good at the way it is
uh maybe it's not perfect it doesn't
take care of
of adults that are younger
are older than juvenile uh but
this would uh be a good thing for
uh our justice system thank you
before i recognize anyone to speak on on
the bill the question can their members
participate remotely are they anyone
else having trouble hearing
the members of the room if so can you
give me a
thumbs up mr chair
representative o'hare the i think the
reason that comes choppy is
uh members in the room that have mics
near their
them are moving papers and that is
uh making the mic go to that
person and that's why it becomes choppy
and takes away from the other person
they're not doing it now but during some
people were speaking some people were
moving papers
by the mics and that would be uh taken
away from the conversation
it may have been me i apologize now
can you guys get this okay that was
definitely me
that was the chair and i apologize for
that a few more minutes to look for that
thank you mr chair representative muse
thank you mr chair i i believe this is a
bill that
uh that we should be passing not
retaining
um i think we heard a lot of convincing
uh testimony uh
just about the fact that um the people
of the age
that we're talking about um essentially
don't have fully developed brains yet um
and well they're definitely capable of
of horrible actions just as adults
are capable of those actions to hold
them
up for the worst
punishment that our justice system can
offer
with no chance of having an opportunity
for parole no matter how much they've
developed or how much they've changed
their lives afterwards seems to be
a very harsh thing uh that
really is unfitting uh for our justice
system
so i would urge you uh to
reject the retaining motion and uh and
hopefully we can
move to an odd to pass motion
representative catherine you're
recognized
same here um i agree with everything
that was said
um with my colleagues um i really think
it's important that we do remember the
situation in terms of
the frontal lobe that was given there
was quite a bit of testimony
testimony from the right people or the
medical
people as well as documentation
so i we have to remember that
until you're in your mid-20s your mind
is still really growing developing and
especially
for reasoning and things of that nature
so
to send someone to uh prison for
a lifetime and i think i mentioned when
i um actually
opened this for uh representative burch
that there was a man um i think then i
said he was 86 but he was 83 years old
that was released
just the day before we actually had the
hearing on this
and that's a long time and what they
said was when he was in his 70s
he went before the board and they were
going to release him but they wanted him
to be on parole
but he wanted to be a free man he hadn't
been a free man
free person since he was a teenager
so he declined that and then finally
at age 83 they released him
as a free man so um
i it really disturbs me that we would
even
think to give a child a life sentence
any child and as stated before
most of the states have done away with
that
so um i really think that new hampshire
is better than that to be honest with
you
so that's my two cents on that so i
believe
that the bill is fine the way it is and
that it should go forward
representative you're recognized yes
thank you mr speaker i miss the chairman
i i agree with thunder and i would like
to say that
we're not setting them free they're
going before a judge
and there's a parole voting whatnot that
listens to what they say and i think a
lot of people
change um during the years
and they should be giving a second
chance thank you
representative newman you were
recognized
thank you mr chair i also agree that
sentencing a child to
life without parole um takes away all
chances of rehabilitation
and i think we've all read about people
that have committed murder
and rehabilitated themselves to the
point where they have degrees
and they teach and they help out in in
the prison even though they have no
possibility of ever being released
and i think it's almost cruel and
unusual punishment
to give that kind of sense
did it
uh representative
thank you mr chair this time it is about
the bill
and i think looking at it
this is a very important bill for new
hampshire when we are facing
such a shortage i mean heart
youngsters to be life imprisoned
and not have a chance of uh parole
we are just the human potential and i
think this
is just not right
action to take and i think we need to
look at
what's available to us in how do we
harness because it's very
evident the science scientific studies
evolving brain this gives those
uh youngsters an opportunity we have the
opportunity to train
and shape those minds while they are
imprisoned and make that
wrong the right in terms of neurological
growth
and i think this would be a hindrance
if we retain it let us uh i think
looking at the bill looks like a good
one to
uh our department
senator
the other thing is um
commissioner hanks sent us documentation
i hope that everybody took the time to
take a look at that documentation
um i think if i remember correcting now
it was
four or five
people in there that at the time they
committed the crime they were 17 years
old
in the state of new hampshire i don't
remember and i don't have it in front of
me
what age they are now but again i just
like to encourage the team that um
remember it's called rehabilitation
people are not people are sent there for
their crime
but also for rehabilitating so that's
all i have to say thank you
representative thank you mr jim
i just want to simply state that one
on the motion to retain i will be voting
against it
for the simple basic reasons that a lot
of people have already expressed
i feel it's uh it's not appropriate to
retain this so
and what else can they the underlying
bill
as it's written under every circumstance
there'll be no circumstance where a
juvenile should be sentenced to
right now on the new hampshire law that
would that would be applicable for a
juvenile
uh his first degree murder second degree
murder
and then a third conviction of felony
sexual assault
those are the situations where a
juvenile would face
a life sentence a
second degree murder it's not a
mandatory bison therefore it's the
second degree murder
charge which uh for sentence would not
be
in violation of
miller versus alabama in 2012
as written our first
first degree murder sentence for a minor
would violate that provision
so there is some we could do some
housekeeping work which is why
i would favor retaining the bill so we
can
we can put in the amendments at least
clean up some of the constitutional
inconsistencies
this but in my opinion if this bill is
not retained i would be supporting an
ipl
because i believe it goes beyond the
what the miller decision
uh stated because miller
the mandatory sentence is the problem
and the amendment really would figure
out for a
juvenile charge first degree murder when
would an appropriate time be
that doesn't mean that you also don't
take away the discretion for
a judge to send in someone about
juvenile
life in prison it can still be done the
miller case is not said that can't be
done it just can't
get mandatory sentence i did put some
some i draft together however it will
take some time to bet that that's done
properly
so i would say it's in the interest of
retaining it rather than putting
something forward that i would say i'm
not confident
right but when i'm hearing about the
brain development
and people talk about the mid-20s i know
this
reference before i i don't have the
exact age but i know
the situation that happened just south
of uh new hampshire massachusetts
i thought i think the
18 or 19 but either way they're not in
their mid-20s
their brain is not fully developed what
that person did was let off two bombs in
the city of boston
injured several people a child was
killed
five days later they murdered a police
officer full of blood
and then we've got a shootout police
officers in watertown
in the presidential neighborhood and
what i'm hearing today is that that
person's praying you know that person's
not juveniles
that that person would be unusual to
send
that person to a life sentence nevermind
yep so uh i think
i believe it goes to this as britain
would go too far
but i think that there's there is some
work you could do if it's retained
i would be i would assure the members of
this committee that i would work with
them
to put some drought forward that
i would support and pass but that's
written i would support an idea
representative you're recognized thank
you mr chairman
and um i agree with everything that
you've said
uh you know the miller case is very
clear
um
helen hank sent us some information that
i still have more questions too
and i think we really need to look at
because i think one of our
representatives said it and then also
a couple other people said it that were
testifying in support of this
bill that this is just a stepping stone
to age 24.
so i think we need to look at all of
that
so retain really is the right motion at
this point
so we can look at those things that i
have concerns about
and like you said if this does not pass
then i'm entertained in 19-0
representative hopper uh thank you mr
chair and i agree
a lot of what people have said about how
the
brain of teenagers it's really not even
close to develop
and we should do something but the fact
of the matter
is if we decide this today or november
for somebody serving a life sentence
without parole it will make no
substantial difference and holding off
and doing it right
is what i'm going to vote for
and representative harvard i i will i
agree with what you said
in the miller case uh the support was
very clear that it applies retroactively
so if there was
a minor or juvenile who sentenced a
mandatory sentence of life without
people in the state of new hampshire
that's something the miller case would
still apply that came out in 2012 so i
would be surprised
that i would be surprised to hear that
there's still a
that hasn't been addressed already but
i have i haven't reviewed all the
information representative
yes i could support your um
interim study if you are going to be
sure that you're going to write
something that would be bad
representatives i gave you my word that
i've already drafted something but it
this is not my area of expertise uh
and i want to make sure that it's it's
done right it
is kind of bouncing around to several
rsas it would take time
in my time where i'm not in a public
area i do work full-time
i have a family i do my best but i i
want to make sure if something is put
forward
uh it's done right and then obviously
give the members the time to absorb
what it does it does not but again as
written
uh i think this is going in the
direction of an idea because
representative thank you thank you mr
chairman
yes when i spoke before and then you
spoke i had a follow-up to you
and my follow-up has to do with the fact
that
i have a hard time thinking that a
juvenile in the category of
16 to 18 years old
is totally lost and we just throw him in
jail
and give him no chance for parole and
i'm not saying that the parole board's
going to let them out
they got to review it and see what's
what and i'm saying
i have a hard time saying we want to
just throw this kid in jail
and wash our hands up i'm not in that
category of a christian
i think they have to have a chance at
parole
[Music]
thank you um this is more of a
clarification for the chair um because
i respect that it sounds like the
committee
does take this concern really serious
and if there really is an
uh overreach in this bill i just don't
understand it so if you could explain
that to me because
as i understand the wording of this
right now it just says that we can still
uh sentence a minor to life
we just as it stands on the books
they're not allowed to have any hearing
so i thought that what this would do was
say we can still sentence them to life
but
they are allowed a hearing at some point
i don't understand where the overreach
or the
the what needs to be clarified or
how it goes too far if you could explain
that to me
or try again i know you just spoke but
i've only
stayed in my in my humble opinion
not speaking and members of the
committee so
if if a juvenile sentence to life in
prison
that's they still could be announced a
possibility cold that's
that's correct but if that is something
what this bill does it would take the
discretion away during the sentencing
hearing
that there would be no circumstance
where a juvenile would be sentenced to
life
without any exception whatsoever
this would this takes away that
exception
that goes i also will say
that if the first degree murder which as
written
is a mandatory life in person without
venomous control if a juvenile were to
be convicted of first degree murder i
guess the question
we can consider
when putting together an amendment is
when would that juvenile
field rule comparing it to
second-degree murder although a person a
juvenile could be sentenced to life
uh in person without the vote for second
humor
at the discretion during the sentencing
here
for that situation if no
fixed time period is assigned then
that juvenile would be eligible for 18
years
so again it's not just simply putting an
amendment in
my humble opinion i like it i think it's
worth discussing as a committee
and making sure it's done right but i
also think we can clean up some
language uh to make sure that the
holding from milligrams to alabama is at
least
on the bus i think at the very least we
did that but also
by doing that we got to then maybe see
how we want the rest of the proceeds
together
but that's not something that i felt
that would be done very quickly and then
making sure that it's done right because
there's several rsa simplicity
representative collin you're recognized
thank you mr chairman i appreciate the
thought that you and other committee
members have put into this and
and really wanting to get it right um
i think the bill uh i think the bill is
okay as it is
um i'd like to see it get to the floor
this year i'd like to defeat the
retaining motion and make another motion
um i think there's been a lot of
viewpoints offered today retaining
closes this door
i'd like to see a chance at at otp or
itl and see where it falls
but um retaining i don't think we're
going to get to a different result next
year i think
we have the bill let's vote on it now
let's get it to the floor
representative testament you recognize
thank you mr chairman
uh i think i'll
support the retaining of the bill not
because i don't believe
that the bill has merit
but you know i was going to say this
earlier and i
what really bothers me we've got a lot
of people here talking about
how horrible it would be to do something
would be a permanent situation
for a young person before
their minds are completely formed
and i put a bill forward it got voted
down for exactly that reason
uh and it turned out
you know i was just saying it's not
right to
have an operation or drugs
to change a child's sex now that's
obviously something
that couldn't be fixed because they
hadn't had a chance to
to reach the age of you know all their
brain developing
i just find it sort of
unreasonable for for some people who i
know are against that kind of a bill
to be in support of it in a situation
like this it just doesn't make any sense
you're not consistent
i'm going to support you
nice way you could put it represented
all right and and i i just when i say
that we're retaining it that's not
i'm just as written i believe the bill
goes too far but there is there is some
falses we can put into place
i think with with potential amendments
and i would also put out that any
subcommittee that we have whenever
we're able to meet all members of the
committee are still allowed to
participate
but obviously not all voting subjects so
this is something that i'm willing to
work on with everyone together
but uh i would be advocating for an
ideal as written and i would
probably support you
[Music]
representative you're recognized thank
you mr chairman i think that it's going
to be a question toward you
my good friend from manchester um i
value his opinions
he's absolutely right about us putting
young people in prison forever and just
throwing the key away i i do support him
on that
but i believe and i hope you can clarify
that the military
has taken care of that pretty much
saying that yes we
might have four people on there but they
do have a possibility for parole is that
correct
so i don't know the facts and
circumstances of the
four of five juveniles that is currently
serving
life sentence i agree with with the
words
from the representative as well i agree
that just simply having a mandatory
life in prison without rule as a
penalty or a punishment for a crime to
apply to a juvenile
is not appropriate and the miller case
specifically said they cannot have
accounting and mandatory life without
the world
so the miller case from the military
alabama 2012
has already solved that problem this is
what this is taking him a step further
with no circumstance whatsoever
regardless of how many 17 year olds can
kill 200 people
on 200 different occasions and would not
be able to serve
a sentence to life in prison
so what i'm saying is that there should
be some exception
that i believe the judgment has the
discretion which familiar case allows
the court to still have a juvenile
sentence political it's just a matter of
not being mandatory so going through the
rsas and finding all of the
circumstances where juvenile could be
sentenced to life
in prison or whether it's management
that's what i was doing
trying to figure out which rsas are will
be implicated and if the
juvenile is not going to serve i'll let
you send
i think it's important for us to figure
out what should that
be the appropriate time for you to be
out of the role and that's something i
think
all twenty one of us can contribute to
that whether we
support the amendment or not i still
think people contributed our members
contributed to that
conversation would be productive because
[Music]
i was thinking 25 years in my mind i i
think that's
apollo mr chairman representative thank
you
and um so i hope my friend from
manchester um
you know will see because i am going to
vote to retain
because i still have a lot of questions
and with those questions we'll be able
to vote later on
not to pass or itl um
but by retaining it it will allow us to
look at these issues that we're looking
at and
further you know to make it into this
because i agree you know if somebody
kills
200 people um you know there's a problem
here
um but you know if it's a you know
you know every life is valuable and you
know we need to make sure that we look
at that
so if i
if you're in in prison for a long time
and you have a possibility for parole
and you're supposed to be rehabilitating
you you work through that
at some point you've changed your mind
and you try to become a model
prisoner if there is no possibility for
parole
you can do any damn thing you want
thank you
uh
[Music]
after until april so
and we would have a deadline you know we
need to see this bill
uh die on the table because we didn't
properly vetted amendment
i i would also say if you were not in
some of the restrictions that we would
have been this might have been something
we could have worked on but it's very
complicated but i
when i say i've already put my own
personal graph together
it's helpful so i would also
value the input of other members on
submitting that so that's why i think
the benefit of the subcommittee
would benefit from bill and i think i
evaluated his opinion
[Music]
thank you mr chairman my final comments
at this time will be i can understand
retain but if i'm one of the
five families in new york to get
together and have a meeting
they get to a point where they say i
need an assurance
that such and such is going to happen
that's what i'm
asking here now because if you retain
something
as i understand it it could very easily
die in the shuffle it just gets
a retained bill could die in retain
especially like with coven we get
another upsurge and all of a sudden
we're not meeting
anymore i have a hard time with that so
i'm thinking about it can i get some
assurance that we're gonna
bring this bill back to retain with some
new provisions in it soon
i assure you this
i would swear anything you want that
i've already put a draft
i would swear on anything that you asked
me that i already put
it together after afterwards
[Music]
it's a complicated subject
it's a complicated subject so i'm not
comfortable that my vetting
process is done and then i
would value the members of this
committee's input
on that policy as well so when i say
that it's been done
and it's already insiders so it's not
going anywhere even if i went somewhere
it's not going
thank you
representative newman
thank you mr chair and given those
unofficial assurances i am going to vote
reluctantly revoke to retain the bill
and just hope we do everything we can to
make sure
that it gets a fair hearing this year
thank you
representatives yes thank you mr chair
i um i just think we can
retain it and bring it out in january
at the first session and i'm gonna
i think we've had a very healthy
discussion on this
so i'd like to vote
see see no hands raised
sorry i was not raising my hand i can
hear you
i'm gonna we're gonna move the questions
i was advised to put your uh
representative gathered you need to try
your video
let's see how hands raised the matter
would now
uh be put to question uh if you were in
favor of the motion to retain please say
yay if you were opposed
[Music]
no representative wallace
yes representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
pratt
representative marston yes
yes representative harry gathering
yes representative panzelakis
yes representative over
yes representative board name
yeah representative muse
yes representative newman
yes representative
yes representative finally
no representative
knight no representative bradley
no chairman chair votes yes
mr chair vote is 17-day morning
i voted 17 years and four days the
motion to retain
house bill 632 just passed
this time we're going to close the
executive session on health bill
632.
yes i think we need to explain that
when a bill goes is retained that it can
come out
with a new bill in the next session
which will be in january
and we will get it right
thank you and i only get to base my
experience the last term that we would
likely have
an executive session on this in the fall
and i'm hoping that
so hopefully sooner rather than later we
can start having the subject mates work
on the entertainment
thank you this time we would not close
the executive session the house bill 632
the movement in recess to 11
15 and we do have
another bill for reconsideration and
will likely
have the executive session senate
foreign
i thought we were recessed until 11.
i think it's 11 15. okay
sorry linda i'm gonna have to leave
okay um i'm good with okay
you coming back no i have um
test to be taken oh
okay
but i'll stay for 15 minutes or so
and did he give you any reason why we're
gonna
reconsider a 19-0 vote
yeah i put it in an email it wasn't in
the committee
it wasn't in the committee when we
re-voted that's what happened
so um the clerk said
that because it was already passed
with the itr that we couldn't vote on
that
we were wrong to take the vote
okay
um
laura you're muted
you know what i they might have gone to
caucus or something because i can't see
in the room and i haven't seen anybody
either
oh jeez
no i got things to do too
i never seen anything like this never
before if i seen so many door openings
no all right i was just gonna text him
what are you cooking laura no
i got two little um leprechauns
in there waiting for me
we we need to remember this is the live
recording that's being
going up yeah i know
we're not saying anything bad
i'm just falling apart i have to go have
some tests taken
well i think
i just think you need a minor tune-up oh
[Music]
probably true right
11 20 already
you know you're the only one allowed to
be angry as the dean of the house
so i would use that to your advantage
[Music]
taking some pages out of your book thank
you
i have two two little leprechauns
waiting for me to come in
[Music]
oh
so we're today andrew was that
no work today no
is
and uh i think there's some background
noise being recorded on your end
yeah i'll mute when i when they come in
yeah i'm in the hospital so it
definitely is and right now i'm not
muted
right now it sounds like a radio or
something it's a tv
did you text him linda
i did he didn't respond
thank you
um
representative is that you beeping
oh yeah that's here
oh the beeping is uh there okay
thank you representative mandy poody for
joining us today
i love seeing your smiling face
i'm trying to keep my smile
although sometimes i want to scream or
cry but that's okay
i always look to you and i i know
when you start crying i start crying
now we we can keep keep going
good to be part of this
we folks
no
um mr chairman could we take up
senate bill 43 because i have to leave
to go for a test
i i will tell you representative said uh
although i did say we would likely
accept
senate bill 34 i don't believe that we
actually do that today
okay thank you
at this time we reopened the executive
session
on house bill 598
i was adopted for a course of a new
incentive to serve
reconsideration
did you say me yes okay
yes i like the most um motion for
reconsideration for house bill 598
reconsideration has been seconded by
representative pantholakis
all right hold on one second
there's a lot of noise here so i
apologize um
yes um as i stated before that i had a
lengthy conversation with commissioner
hanks
who is very much feel as though this is
a good bill but needs some work and
she's willing to work with me
um as well as work with um len
and there was a few other names that she
had mentioned
like i said i'm not home i wrote
everything down
and we definitely want to work on this
bill together
and bring it back to the bring it back
to the committee
so that's the essence of why i asked for
reconsideration because then i'm going
to ask to retain it
thank you
seeing no hands raised uh the matter
will now be put to question if you in
favor of the motion of reconsideration
please say yay if you're opposed
please
vice chairman welch
hi representative burke
yes representative popper
yes representative greene
yes representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative representative pratt
representative marston yes the park
votes yes
representative harriet gaffrey yes
representatives
yes representative o'hara
yes representative
yes representative muse
yes representative newman
yes
yes representative conley yes
representative yes
representative bradley yes
chairman chair votes yes mr chair vote
is 20
yay one minute i voted 20 a's and
one maze the motion um
everybody went through this once today
but we'll uh
i will take the uh recommendation from
representative
and unfortunately i believe there was
the most
of that excuse me to legislate
that motion was made by representative
hurt
paul yes and seconded by wallace
now the second american wallace
if both those numbers wish that we draw
that i will we will still get to keep up
[Music]
would a member wish to make a motion to
withdraw that
makes me delicious that's uber
there a second yeah second by
representative hopper
seeing him
i have a question representing you
recognized
yeah um i as i understood it we don't
have to do
this with the i if they pulled if they
um pulled it back so why are we doing it
now you are 100
correct in that you do not have to do
this
it was justified
it's true yeah i'm just saying that we
just need to be consistent that's all
because
if we do it different than what we did a
few minutes ago it
just seems like we're not consistent
with how we're supposed to do things
that's all
we
[Music]
is that it's not necessary to do a roll
call vote
to withdraw the motion but it is a
practice that can be done
uh thank you mr chair for for calling on
me uh
i'm i'm i'm certainly going to defer to
you uh as the chair of the committee
um i would just note that um
the the the fact of the matter is that
um
by taking the reconsideration vote
you've undone
the prior vote um so
uh withdrawing emotion is proper
um and as long as the seconder also
agrees to withdraw the motion
it to to take a vote on something
that is is frankly sort of ministerial
um is just it's just irregular
um i i understand the concerns
raised by uh the two gentlemen uh on the
committee
um but because essentially the the vote
was undone uh by your action
um a emotion again
you don't have to withdraw it you can
simply vote down the motion because it
was still before you as well
um but a motion to just to withdraw
emotion is is just something that is a
ministerial thing
thank you mr clark and i think that was
uh i i
thank you for your time and thank you
for the explanation i think given
that again this being a live reported
hearing
and the public was able to hear that
that
it would be irregular for us to take a
vote on some of the things
wrong that we've already considered so i
think at this point
i would recognize uh representative
gathered for a motion for retain
i like the promotion out that we retain
i think i've talked quite a bit about
this bill um
you're expecting that motion to repeat
oh secondary
that has been that motion to retain been
seconded by representative anthologist
anyone wishes to speak uh on the motion
to retain
all right open
representatives
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
clarifying and following
consistent rule and i appreciate that it
was very confusing
when a few minutes ago what was and i'm
glad you
uh were able to clarify and thanks to
clerk paul for paul smith for clarifying
i appreciate it
seeing no uh seeing no hands raised the
matter would now be first
question if you were in favor of the
pain you'd say yes
you were opposed please
thanks jeremy welch hi representative
burke
green no representative wallace
yes representative testerman yes
representative true mary representative
pratt
no representative marston
yes clark votes yes
representative harriet gaffrey yes
representative pantalakis yes
yes representative ordnay
yes representative muse
yes representative newman yes
representative yes
representative conley
tari yes representative klein knight
yes representative bradley
yes chairman chairman yes
mr chair of the vote
i voted 17 years and four names the
motion to retain it from cloud
this time with the executive session
on house till 598 before we adjourn
just one housekeeping matter and i will
assure you that if you have any
questions about this that um do a much
better job of explaining this to myself
last during the last time we met we
did a reconsideration in of a retained
bill
he was hd 576.
after the reconsideration
we then in the motionbox
despite that uh unification amongst the
committee on that until
he when the bill was retained earlier
it was delivered to the clerk and by the
bill being
delivered to the clerk despite being
retained it was actually no longer
in our committee and for that reason uh
it was not proper for us to reconsider
the bill and then to vote on it both on
the
chats although that was a good exercise
and
i should say good exercise to the main
correct procedural matter if not
essentially that that whole
reconsideration then off the task
would not be it's not proper because the
bill of the money
that bill would is will remain uh
continue to be retained by the committee
uh considering what uh what we voted on
i can imagine that we will eventually
pass that field
this time just to clarify the members
that bill would not be
uh leaving this committee has not
defended us
so i apologize for confusion
there's not there's not much we can do
about that
representative thank you mr j could you
clarify the clarification
uh beginning with uh what bill we're
talking about
so it was hb 576
that we retained well we initially
retained hp576
after we retained it completely the
public hearing was on march 3rd
the builders retained the executives
it was it was documented on march 9th i
believe on march
10th we opened the public hearing
i'm sorry i reopened the executive
session
and it i there's a motion to reconsider
hp 576 and after this was reconsidered
a motion about the past however because
it was
delivered to the clerk once the bill is
delivered to the court
whether it's any speed to legislate off
the pass
about the past cemented detained the
committee no longer has
it's no longer the possession there will
be not able to take action
i i was unaware that it was you know
delivered
when that action was done so my
understanding is that
all the good work we did in community we
showed on
content was
not a proper procedure to do that so
that motion free consideration and not
to pass themselves would be
nullified and the bill will remain
retained
there's no disrespect to the bill itself
there's no disrespect to
that's just when i went through my
paperwork i was i
i didn't see that it was talking about
but
that's true so i've lost that paperwork
so what
what was the title of what was 576
relative to the victim's compensation
fund eligible
thank you
representatives mr chairman
[Music]
um i have a question for the chair
on hb 576
um so this is
retained because we didn't
do it we didn't reconsider it correctly
the second time is that correct
once any bill is delivered
[Music]
if you have any questions from the court
they can be directed at the clerk
on a separate occasion
but that's the procedure that's uh and
there's not much i can do to
change change what what is happening
representative you're recognized
okay um i understand that but is the
clerk still with us
mark is still with us
okay i have a question of the clerk
i'm here representative okay is it
is there anything that we can do to um
i guess so that the 19-0 vote goes
through
or anything that we can do to what would
it take to pull it back to us or
you know well i'm just not sure and i'm
just asking
sure so the sure the short answer is it
it's it's still with you
uh the issue is that it the the action
um
isn't before the isn't going before the
body at this point
because because you you did vote to
retain it
the list of retained bills was
transmitted to my office and so we
we did docketed accordingly so that
at that point just as if a bill had been
reported out as itl that had been
transmitted to my office
it could not be reconsidered by the
committee um so the list had been
transmitted
um and while the the bill is still
technically in your possession
uh but your your report uh for this year
is that you've retained it for action in
the second year
um you can begin uh uh
as you conclude your work in in on house
bills and senate bills
uh the speaker has indicated that you
can begin retained bill work sessions
uh for for the second year um and
and obviously uh come the fall this this
could be reported out and
and certainly it sounds like it's almost
a consent calendar item
um uh and not being familiar with a
particular bill
uh but but that being said i will say
that this uh that you
uh are not the only committee that has
found themselves in this situation
um there there is a a
an alternative whereby um on the full
floor of the house
a bill could be withdrawn from committee
however um i would suggest that um
that that is not a good practice uh
because it
it essentially is taken away from your
committee because
uh with without a recommendation from
the committee
uh and it sort of makes the committee
look like they have not done
um sort of their their diligence in that
reporting
uh so i do um that is sort of the
situation
on um on that particular bill
thank you okay thank you very much
[Music]
thank you just to further clarify this
question is to
clerk hold smith and uh
so the reta even though it's retained
and it's still
in technically in the position of the
committee
not committee cannot act on it is that
what you're
what you're saying yes representative
amanda putin when a bill is retained by
a committee it means it is retained for
the first year
session uh so that means that uh
technically that the committee has has
opted to do more work on it um over the
over the few months uh in between the
first year and the second year
um there this this obviously we we have
about 120 bills that have been
listed as retained thus far um most of
those have to do
with um things where whereby the
committee does wish to do more work
on on that in that sort of respect
so this is not like the follow-up mr
chair
mine is a question for the clerk
a little bit you recognize here
thank you mr clerk and what what is the
consequence if it
if the bill is not reported out by the
end of the year what's the consequence
in the second year in that case
if we don't get anything done um
you have to um the committees have to
come
back uh in the fall and and report on
all of their
i have an executive session on all of
their bills thank you
um this is um just for executive session
uh unless we're done with that i just
feel like we
made a mistake and the bill's good and
we should fight to overturn this on the
floor
i agree that the bill was good and i
believe that the mistake was made
i'm sure i'm sure we'll get this bill
out of our committee
we would have gone on the train calendar
if not for
situations
[Music]
thank you mr clark for uh assisting the
community today and i
want to thank the members